c'est l'heure pour david saint-jacques
de faire ses bagages
après un séjour de plus de six mois dans
la station spatiale internationale
ses valises rentreront à bord d'une
capsule cargo qu'il a lui même attrapé
avec le bras canadien à bord de soyouz
il ne pourra apporter qu'une toute
petite boîte l'objet n'est plus précieux
on le garde avec nous on peut ramener
sur le soyouz équivalent à peu près
d'une boîte de mouchoirs ou 199e jour de
ses missions il nous parle d'abord du
grand bonheur qui l'aura de retrouver sa
conjointe et ses trois enfants à houston
mais aussi de petits plaisirs terrestres
qui lui ont manqué leurs frais le vent
le soleil on en a quand on regarde par
la fenêtre mais on a pas de vent ici ça
manque
et pourquoi mais l'autre fois j'ai vu un
feu d'une photo d'un feu de camp et ça
m'a vraiment touché ce genre de faire ça
me promener sur la rue où il ya beaucoup
de gens ici c'est toujours les mêmes
visages heureusement c'est des gens
qu'on aime
mais avant de pouvoir se promener il
devra avoir de l'aide pour marcher il
s'attend aussi à subir des malaises et
des nausées
son corps a oublié ce qu'est la gravité
j'ai grandi en l'espace de quelques
centimètres justement parce que ma
colonne vertébrale ces raids récit
complètement il presque plus de courbure
chaque disque s'était élargie en
ramenant sur terre je crois je m'écrase
et encore c'est à dire éviter ça il
paraît que ça peut être pénible
astro physiciens ingénieurs et médecins
david saint jacques et ses collègues ont
fait un nombre record d'expérience et de
travaux depuis le début de décembre
ce qui est extraordinaire dans
l'émission de david c'est qu'il faut
énormément de science l'équipage de la
station spatiale au cours des deux
semaines a établi des records en terme
de productivité pour les derniers jours
l'astronaute fera surtout de la révision
pour se remettre en tête les manoeuvres
qu'il devra exécuter à bord du vol de
retour au kazakhstan toutes les
procédures d'un retour sur terre en
soyouz
mais il faut le maîtriser au bout des
doigts j'étais présent au lancement et
au kazakhstan extrêmement nerveux pour
le retour c'est aussi difficile mais
c'est des choses qu'on a déjà fait
y'a rien d'improvisé la prochaine
mission avec un astronaute canadien
devrait être fixé d'ici 2024
puis le canada pourrait éventuellement
avoir la lune dans sa mire
ici anne louise despatie radio canada
longueuil